Here we can see that the waves with the long wavelengths are what we perceive
as red, and this wavelength be about 750 nanometers. The shortest wavelength
that we can perceive corresponds to violet light. And it's about 400
nanometers. Just longer than violet, is blue and then green, yellow and orange.
&gt;&gt; So, when we perceive color our eyes are just taking in different wave lengths
of light?
&gt;&gt; Exactly, and this is where color vision comes in. We talked before about how at
the back of our eyes we have these different photoreceptors, the rods and the
cones.
&gt;&gt; And the cones are the ones for color.
&gt;&gt; Right, and we have three of them.
&gt;&gt; Why do we have three?
&gt;&gt; Well, I think I mentioned this before, that ones for long wavelengths, red and
oranges. Another type of cones is for these medium wavelengths, these greens
and yellows. And still another is for the short wavelengths. And in fact, the
most common type of color blindness, actually makes it hard to distinguish
between reds and greens.